Let's talk a bit about
the Icicles project architecture.
By which I mean the classes
that will make up Icicles.
First, we have IciclesGame,
which is our application listener,
the entry point into our code.
IciclesGame will delegate its
application listener callbacks to one of
two screens.
DifficultyScreen,, which allows the user
to select the difficulty of a game.
And IcicleScreen,
which contains the actual gameplay.
IciclesScreen uses two other classes
to hold the state of the game world.
There's Player, which handles the
position of the little stick figure down
at the bottom of the screen and
also manages user input.
And then, there's Icicles, which manages
the position of all the icicles.
Icicles itself, is basically, a
collection of a bunch of icicle objects.
Finally, we'll be very careful to keep
all constants in their own class.
There's two reasons for this.
The first is that when constants
are spread all over the place,
it becomes incredibly frustrating to
find the number that you want to tweak.
If you want to change, for instance, how
fast the icicles drop, you might need to
drill down into IciclesGame, and
then go find an IciclesScreen, and
maybe it's in Icicles,
maybe it's in the Icicle singular class.
Who knows where it is?
We'll just keep all of those
constants in their own class.
Even more important, is the fact that
when you develop games in a professional
context, you're often building
a platform that allows artists and
designers to easily
slot in their content.
You need to design your game in such
a way that your game designer can
add a new weapon, or
change some balance easily.
Or your artist can swap out some art
assets, all without needing your help.
Rigorously using a constants class
is a baby step in this direction.